throws a good throw a good welcome I'm
sure everyone knows but just to get the
ball rolling can you tell us how
Sherlock began everyone in this room
could tell you how it began
but would you want us to do it again do
you that's that's one person at the time
to do one word marking me on the train
discussing Doctor Who realising everyone
was listening to us we had to discuss
something else
so we business journal combs our equal
obsession mark your bet we talked about
how we loved the buzzer Rathbone films
the most and the the ones where they
updated them to the Second World War the
most and we looked at each other and
thought well someone should do that
against a brilliant idea
and because we were in the middle of
another Afghan war he was a strange
coincidence that's that's how it starts
anyway so it was a natural way in the
orbit I then mentioned to my wife that
we were very very cross at the idea that
somebody else might one day make a
modernized version of Sherlock Holmes
when it really should with us and she
looked at me uncomprehending as I wept
and said well you could do it and that
did seem like a revelation and so we had
a meeting in Monte Carlo no we did where
we pitched Sherlock Holmes too soon and
we did a pilot and he got off I may have
skipped a bit
you want to know how to find out what's
going to be in season four
watch season 4 micro sign of quite an
ambiguous character at the beginning of
the series I mean and I know it's a he
changed his relationship which shows had
to change into more he was about
prominent figure in Sherlock's life and
are we going to see him become much more
involved in series 4 watch series 4 this
is easy
Lamarque the adventure drives Sherlock
that's his motivation and what is my
Crofts motivation because there's a
scene that really quite upset me
watching as he was a decided Christmas
Eve on New Year's Eve
and he's sitting alone looking into the
fire and that was really a tragic
heart-wrenching sequence what what is
Mycroft
it's like a Cyberman I think with me he
substituted power for all his emotions
well I think it's it's organization I
think he's a he's a very tidy mind and
he and Sherlock is is outside the tent
anyone's in him but I think he's
isolated there's no one else in that big
house and the brightest except the
running machine the suit of armor he
does a lot of diets a lot of diets I'm
seeing your job to keep these two boys
in order
yeah they're going easy to keep in order
I mean there's such fans that the only
thing have to do is stop them talking
and start writing and re excitedly that
we had a very exciting the other day and
it was as it always is it's just really
just like sort of being at the
playground getting excited
yep there we go hi doctor hey mister by
a whole show I'm still missing him
thank you by the way for making Matt
Smith that was amazing but my question
is this at the start the empty hearse
there's a lot of you saw answered how
shall have died in a bunch of ways and I
realize you know it's to make the
audience so imagine their own different
way of them you know answering the
question you don't really want to kind
of given me an exact answer but is there
one I mean because Addison adds doubt to
the end of that when that show up tells
him doesn't he I'm his only anderson who
dosed the truth when he's told it look
there's only one version of the death
that works yeah unless you think that
really that dummy would have worked with
the face and you really think the Darren
Bruins by the way my favorite yeah is my
favorite too it's what he finally it's
almost treating Anderson as if he's a
Sherlock fan who having been given the
answer simply didn't accept it and
wanted another one yeah hello
but in your look you know can I just say
this after all this time if you wash the
Reichenbach Fall again for the 800 time
you will know the John Watson cannot see
the point of impact right so it's really
dead simple as Sherlock failed something
got between him and the pavement there's
no other way there's no other way to
avoid dying right Horace no the TARDIS
isn't real or is just keeping it going
we go ten years it's gone you guys are
stoned deed by design Twitter reactions
and Facebook reactions to when each
episode goes oh because it's just
internet milkman I think we're standing
by everything we're standing by this I
mean this was what we thought was gonna
be a great show on BBC Two and we
thought it would be well we thought we
thought it would be a good 1050 BC One
BBC Two's show so it was never gonna be
music - don't go back but we didn't know
it was gonna do this nobody's it is
amazing and I mean our non announcement
the other day that we were being
commissioned sort of exploded the
internet they made to the news which I
thought was such as thanks for bringing
up the failure I don't know I think the
truth is people took people showed up in
the first place
for Sherlock before they'd ever seen it
it was it was already a hit because the
there was a huge audience for the first
show so how did they know they were
going to like it is the question it must
just have been exactly the right moment
for people to watch an updated Sherlock
Holmes because it turned out to be good
they carried on showing up but you know
it must just have been that it must have
caught the wave of the Ray moment that
we failed to catch on Jack
no sir Stephen that Mark have said that
they're at becsher liqueurs fine so for
your a Holmes fan at all or is it a job
shamefully I had never read a seller her
story at that point and now I have in my
defense okay in my defense when they
write to spit obviously is no plot of
the original show homes and Colin Doyle
things in there and so I take the part
of the audience that hasn't met all the
stories and then I can make sure it
works from a viewers point of view from
the script as opposed to being as shown
up with Holmes fan and that's my excuse
and I'm sticking to it
well thank God you you you bravely
resist doing all that work you are
within slopping distance and mark and
stephen you spoke about your love of
basil Rathbones at home son were there
any other that made an impact on you
well yes I mean they all do this you
know
in McAllen is about to play Sherlock age
93 and then he's about the 75th actor to
play him but obviously Jeremy Bret's
when we're growing up but the other
principal influence is the Billy Wilder
film that the private life of Sherlock
Holmes which is a masterpiece and then a
huge influence on on our show and the
tone of our show is its humour and its
melancholy as well I think it's that we
can exclusively announce we've just
discovered this is Eric's is there an
exciting thing of the day the blu-ray of
private life is about to come out and
someone has found the audio of the
missing epilogue in which the Inspector
Lestrade comes to Baker Street that says
there's been some murders in the East
End mr. Witte terribly exciting my god
this is the most exciting thing that's
ever happened to us the audio of the
epilogue of a film you haven't seen
that's our unknowns them for today
another question please
hiya obviously whether you call it
rudeness or banter or what Sherlock has
a lot of one-liners and I was just
wondering if any of you have a favourite
particular line um I always like I think
what's it like inside your funny little
brains is an instance statement of
intent of him being not like there's a
very good rejoinder that Sherlock has to
align from Lestrade that Mark originally
wrote and then cut the ice stole for one
of my scripts and cut so I'm not gonna
tell you what it is it's very funny I
think that yeah one day we're getting in
don't you think you've any points when
he tells
Andersen's turn around knowing the IQ of
the do you find that when he dead to the
best man speech he was the most human
person in that room because all came
from his heart which was wonderful I
thought it made him one of us really
well you'll never quite be one of us but
you know the interesting thing about
Sherlock is easy he's a human being he
never he he works to suppress his
emotions to make his brain work better
that means he has emotions in DD he
means he has enough emotion that they
could get in the way so yeah he can't be
emotional he protests a bit too much
because he describes himself as a
calculating machine everything and then
you you can clearly see at the stories
that that's not true he's pushing things
down he's trying to conquer his emotions
and eventually there is real there is
real developments he's not the same man
in the last story is easier beginning
because dr. Watson does humanizing a
little bit another question please
what series for it's easy to say that
but we're not sure if really if Sherlock
telling the truth about those middle
names he might be just a gag you know
Sherlock actually means blonde so he's
all none of it works really Debbie hi
in terms of personality which of the
show-up cows is most similar to their
character
none of them are lying similar anything
the question
well you ngerous exactly is lower police
whistles yes that's for each overlay
unit as Michelle
I mean Benedict is very different so
though he was a rubbish insole he'd
wander around the crime scene asking for
a double latte in a car home he would be
say this history question though and I'm
not going to give it up another question
please stand up thank you hello it's the
doctor this is for both Steven Moffat
and Mark Gatiss my question is what was
the most difficult thing about modern
like modernizing Sherlock in terms of
like making it relevant you know to
today's society that genuinely the most
difficult thing was there was a there
was an instant rush of things ideas we
have because there were certain things
which just worked like instead of
telegrams texts having three nicotine
patches there were three pipe problem
things like that was just fun but the
biggest problem was the question of
whether he could still work in a in a
world of forensics in a CSI way and and
the conclusion we came to basically was
that he's always still the cleverest man
in the room and even though Scotland
Yard now do the things they didn't do in
the Victorian era he is still the one
who could make all the unlikely
connections and that makes him still a
sort of superhero real there's a couple
of other sort of trivial ones we did
bulk for a moment of what they were
going to have to call each other because
in the stories and all the movies they
call each other Holmes and Watson and so
actually saying it's like John and
Sherlock otherwise they're probably
schoolboys that was tough and the one
that we completely bridled out could not
do even though is not in the original
snow
is we had to put two-to-one beyond the
door even though that makes no sense at
all you never have to be on the door
that comes from a Hollywood but we
wanted to put the two-two-one beyond the
door so mark and me could stand next to
the door and be photographed but no
other reason we do every year every year
do you know that up at the Sherlock
Holmes Museum as a door next to it it's
an old brass plate and it says Moffatt
and Sons they know now that so you
involved in the casting process of
Sherlock and John Watson yeah
we've been all the main close together
she is actually the boss
she involved in every session in terms
of casting Sherlock
he's very I don't see doctor Girish but
he does of that sort of alien type
quality and is that what you were
looking for when casting Sherlock I mean
we were looking for because obviously I
don't like Sherlock so well I had to ask
but they you know you described them as
being tall with I think you said big
nose originally yes actually I've seen
that memories and piercing eyes and we'd
be watching atonement when we saw
Benedict in that so I said well could it
be somebody like that so we met Benedict
he was the only one we met for the part
tour the BBC were fine and then we we
short read about three people that we
did a sort of her and meet with Benedict
so he waked with all with about three
different John Wilson's and then when
Martin came in the room at the end of
the chemistry between the drone of first
instant and the two of them just sat
there and said there's our show before
another question please there we go face
boy hi sorry yeah and I understand
between seasons two and three there's
the almost two year gap in the series
for Johnny
two year gap yes yes and that happened
in this evening but I understand because
we're waiting well that happened or at
John and Sherlock do you mean will levy
will it be two years later on in the
story watch season four do you go out of
your way to provide catchphrases that
can go in t-shirts because that's no
good to be in the teacher watch season
four you can actually I mean that we've
had a bit of a running joke about what
you've got a t-shirt but I think
catchphrases you that you can't force
them on the public I'll digress briefly
but I remember when Larry Grayson to go
with a generation game and because
brucey had thousands of brilliant
catchphrases and they gave Larry
graceful at the end the conveyor belt
where he said what a lot she's got the
silence and it's just they dropped it
after about three weeks just didn't work
so you gotta be careful you can't force
these things but things just pop up
really like that this is if you one
watch season four next please great hi
would there be a possibility with comic
relief for children and a need to see
a Doctor Who Sherlock cross I know he
got it right we know what you're going
to ask know what she sees as it was
watch season for someone okay so much
don't want on YouTube which is really
brilliant I thought it's amazing but
they've all I've always thought the
version that people have in their heads
of this entirely ridiculous idea is is
always going to be better than what
anyone might come up with because it you
know it'll just be a bit I just don't I
don't I don't personally see the feed
for it and that they obviously exist in
two different universes you could do it
in a for a comic relief thing because it
helped be fun but I always always think
the version everyone's got in their
heads will be better do you think
Sherlock would like the doctor no they
hate each other I mean of course why
would one turn up if the other one was
already there you know it would be
always your one all right and they
bugger off I think the doctor would be
quite enthused or the Matt Smith doctor
it'd have been quite enthused the
Capaldi doctor not so much watch season
eight please come to somes are better
than one and so obviously well reading
all the books growing up and maybe
reading them again there's so much
information that so many repetitive
stories he kind of lets it go a bit and
repeats himself but how do you pick
which parts you want cuz obviously you
make a lot of changes you make a lot of
adoptions how do you choose how do you
dissect these parts that you want how do
you stick them together from different
plots what's the process really well
they're up there yeah we've obviously
got favorite stories and they do tend to
we keep thinking about us and then if we
sort of generally talking about where
series might go sometimes the story just
presents itself other times there are
just little bits and pieces like the
beginning of Baskerville is
black Peter which is a story that's
we're not going to do but the opening
we're still carrying a harpoon covered
in blood is brilliant so it's about sort
of just cherry picking things like that
really but and we went for season four
we obviously again thinking about some
of our favorites and how they might fit
into an overall series I mean any of the
stories that could be done as a show
we've already done yeah yeah but you
know it's it's it's villains and moments
and gags that people don't know about
we've done all the big stuff we did it
quite early for the hell of it but there
are other villains that aren't as famous
for no particular reason other scenes
other moments another jokes lots of
humor and Doyle and if we've done one
thing right we've mined the humor more
than most people do because they are
funny stories there's an exchange at the
beginning of the valley of fear that's
hilarious between Holmes and Watson sure
we'll get to that at some time another
question please yep right up there very
very very Bank you know it oh this is
first even a mark from a script right
perspective which character is the
hardest character to write for and why
between sorry which character between
words say between sherlock moriarty John
Lestrade Sherlock Holmes is very hard to
write for because he has to be hugely
clever he has to keep demonstrating it
which is why those deductions don't
appear so often as we go we've got to
drop the dial dried up quite a creeper
his birthday they're very if you have to
write someone who's incredibly clever it
pays to be a good of equipment sadly we
omitted that part but no he's easy he's
tough to do the humor know that we've
got into it is I suppose comes to it
comes to us relatively easily and the
and the the lack of manners and so on
but the thing that remains difficult is
he's got to not just say he's clever
he's got to
clever but also with with John Watson
that it is a it is a challenge and it's
it was always a challenges than previous
adaptations that when you read the
stories because he's narrating them
you're very aware of his presence and
the danger with an adaptation is that
he's got nothing to do except make notes
and so to to keep giving Martin a proper
co-lead heart and yet not be constantly
surprised which becomes ridiculous he
can't sit there and go oh good heavens
Holmes quite speaking like aalverson but
you just can't keep that going because
he's obviously got used to it so we've
has we've developed and we thought a lot
more about you know Mary comes in that
she just noticed what Sherlock does
there's no trick so you could sort of
rediscover him through different eyes
now you mentioned humor have there been
any moments during the first three
seasons were you for the great Bailey
last thinking how brilliantly funny it's
been we were talking about an outtake
the sheet oh well there's a famous one
in scandal Belgravia when I stand on
Bendix sheet and reveal his his
nakedness and he was originally it was
quite tightly he's all trussed up he
just about the mowing this she have I
just said only because through laughing
he broke all his teeth another question
please up the other side of the back
money
how these similarities I think I've said
this before it's exceptional dress sense
very nice bottom power though it
happened because we were when we did the
pilot and there was no Moriarty is no
Mycroft and then when we were rethinking
it for a 90-minute format we decided to
to move the whole Moriarty thing up a
lot and then bring in Mycroft and we had
this idea that if we presented him as
Sherlock Holmes's archenemy people with
thing Mycroft was Moriarty and it worked
and I think Stephen said obviously if
you play it I play it they'll think the
only person I would I would arrogantly
watch plays professor Moore here that's
deep that worked as well so it all
worked there was a scene in the first
series and we brought it forward and
Mike Ross trousers were at the they were
being taken out there and so we didn't
have them and but suddenly Marc said oh
I've got a suit at my own Lamar could
have a free one I wear is in which is in
the great game was one of mine because
the trousers have gone missing they
otherwise would be very different scene
another question please see Stephen
following this massive success
congratulations you now have a great
influence over all the generations and
we do set perhaps you have a essential
responsibility to be very careful in
your portrayal of Sherlock's
addictive nature and his addiction to
heroin and could I entreat you to
continue to think about that very
mindfully and thoughtfully in your
excellent production which I enjoy so
much but he was that he's never heroin
never never heroin no miss cigarettes no
it's okay pain you can the morphine
here's what he was and he was if you
look at the original stories he's not
addicted I may have misunderstood but in
fact if you what are the things that we
always get Mike Ross about marking
myself is that is when films present him
as being addicted to anything he's
addicted to solving crimes and he goes
for other highs if he can't get that but
we be it's not a big deal in the stories
it isn't a big deal in the stories you
know so we mostly ignore me had you seen
the nickel Williamson I'm Robert
Duvall's English accent is one of my
favorite things in the world it's a
wonderful book Nick Nick Maher book and
it's a it's actually rather lovely film
it's a brilliant idea I think it's just
one of those ones where Nicole Williams
its portrayal of Sherlock is actually so
far away from Sherlock and then you've
got a very strange dr. Watson it becomes
quite an awesome
it's an oddity that film it's really
worth seeing because the screenplay is
terrific and obviously Robert jovanna
Nicole Williams and are both brilliant
actors but hand on my heart they're just
miscast they're not right and that's why
that film doesn't really fly the way the
screenplay deserves to it's a good
script while they're on it actually
another Sherlock the film well worth
seeking out is a study in terror which
on Neville and don't Houston the
screenplay that is fantastic and it's
really they're very very literate they
really know their stuff fix it it's
about Jack the Ripper it's a really
clever one as now it's got the best set
of non Doyle deductions ever about our
little doctors back and they are
brilliant it is also very funny again
they get the fact that it's meant to be
funny Mycroft's in it great gags Robert
Morley as Mycroft
it's a terrific one we nicked a bit for
Series three because it was on TV is
rarely on and I had texted Stephens
he'll still interest on we watched it in
there this is outrageous ending where
he's in a
burning building and he definitely can't
get out and Adrienne Corrie is there the
the rafters fold and then it just coats
the Baker Street having breakfast in
what's the sister how did you get out of
this if you know my method to us and I'm
well known to be indestructible that's
it but I said that's let's have it
and of course Christopher Plummer Jack
the Ripper he needed to their homes
movies it was a study he did there was
another a Sherlock Holmes versus Jack
the Ripper called murder by decree
that's the line with her he also did a
TV version of silver blaze as well what
do you Jota jury will go through all
this share Lots man
and there are code the jury and noise I
think this album as a sensational actor
and well-suited to I think they they
slightly softened him too much in that
one I thought there is Jack there I put
one I thought he was he wasn't cold
enough I thought they just went over the
line to make him a little bit sweet is a
good movie that I spelt Mia Frank Finlay
playing the start again in both of them
I suspect he might have eaten at the
river is the only evidence here another
question please as time is running out
this mirror stand up yes and what's your
favorite part of making a series of
Sherlock bed
the favorite part of making the series
this is always a depressing thing to
sarah signs it but i really like it when
we finished it and it looks good that's
it actually i would say that the the
first the first sort of ideas meeting we
did this on the last series steve and i
ended up and the the top deck of the
dining bus or something and we sort of
worked out series four and five in a
very exciting afternoon of it and i
think when you just throwing ideas the
wall that's the most exciting bit before
you actually have to commit to writing
hits or paying for it it starts well
this and then it ends well when you
compare this most American dramas which
are on all the time every year yeah yeah
do you feel you benefit from that long
gap that ability to do a couple of
episodes over a longer period do you
find that that's good for you may drive
us nuts happens away but do you think
you could do that same quality if you
had a you know 24 when you're doing it
year I think it's I mean it certainly
makes it feel like an event which is
great and obviously gives us a lot more
time to work on it but I think more than
anything it's the specialness which is
which would go I think if you you know
as it is where we're sort of on for
three weeks then disappear again just in
time to avoid a backlash but it's I
think if we were doing sort of even if
it were possible to do six 90-minute
ones wouldn't feel quite the same and
we've so stumbled on this format but it
does work well but I have to say from
I'm mostly just lost in admiration for
how American series do keep their
quality of is incredible when they do
eight to ten thirteen episodes
ladies and gentlemen times run out of my
fridge so please raise the roof for
so Steven and mom
you